on go el.  the
middle to Getzlaf.
Getzlaf back in after this, rig
free agent coming over from the
Dallll
couture.
>> It's a good bounce for
season, even .500.
all-star gam
appearance earlier this month.
Hegoaltender.
>> Stolarz was stiti THEY NEED
QUICKLY. SAN JOSENET.STRETCHED .
OFF OF THE WALL.
GIVING IT TO
STOPS BUT THE DUCKS' PENALTY  S
1:10. AROUND.
THE GOOD PUCK MOVEMENT.
THE KEY IS THEY'RE ABLE TO GET
HE AND JAMIE DRYSDALE.
TWO POWERFULBUT HIGH
SKILL. CENTER AND IT'S
STEEL WHO SENDS IT IN.
SILFVERBERG SEALS THE POWER PLA.
GETZLAF UP THEPUCK.
BURNS WITH A SHORT PASS BACK.
THE PASS WILL GO RIGHT ON TO
RAKELL RIGHT TO THE LOGO.
CHIP IT I I
>> DEEP TO THE SAN JOSE ZONE.
REIMER, IN
SOME OPPORTUNITIES.HERTL ACROSS
COUTURE.WAY.
THIS WILL BE ICING INSIDE OF THE
FINAL MINUTE OF   LEFT IN OVERT
HAND SIDE.
WE SAW TROY TERRY USE IT BEFORE.
HE CAN